[Music]
this week we've got
new font sexist a.i
and brownie bribes brownie bra i'm
interested in the
font me too ooh comic sans too
oh no times old roman impact menu
i love impact i used to impact all the
time for jk
i liked it yeah but everybody started
using it so now it's like
yeah everyone was using it because
everyone had this
nah you the new [ __ ] right now is babas
their best new yeah
that's like the cleaner version of
impact loser you see oh we've
been here jk has been using it we've
been using it for
years yeah what is it
whatever we've been using that for years
dude that looks like a better
version of impact skinnier impact yeah
so researchers at
rmit university in melbourne remit
they have the meat did you hear how she
said that
melbourne nurse yeah melbourne
melbourners
yeah i learned that's the proper way to
say it so
they invented this new font called sans
for gettica
that's tight ass now how do they
[ __ ] wingdings oh wingdings who the
[ __ ] types
is there wingdings yeah it's the one
with all the symbols yeah
butterfly glasses doorbell station
it's like random [ __ ] when i was in
middle school i had this friend
who sent me this email and like i guess
she was
i don't know like she was upset i can't
even remember what it said but the point
is she put it in a font where it was
like those characters
so i couldn't even read it so you have
to copy and paste and change it yeah all
i did was like highlight it and change
the font i could read everything she
wrote like why did you do that
oh she wrote it in code uh i would have
been that dumb ass friend
sending it to you yeah it was like all
in code but
i forgot she's like she's not gonna know
but i get to get what i want to see
yeah that was and then you just copy and
paste and you're like so you think i'm
fat
i don't know i just remembered that
anyway here's a video
of sam spagetica need help remembering
your study now that [ __ ] looks like new
times raw men
sam's forgetting the first type fact
specifically designed to enhance memory
retention
what spaghettica is the product of a
collaboration between a
multi-disciplinary team of researchers
and academics from rmit
university school of design and
behavioral business lab
the font uses principles of cognitive
psychology to create an effect known as
desirable difficulty
wow obstructions to learning processes
cause the brain to engage in deeper
cognitive processes
that make sense memory retention
available now is a free download and
as a chrome browser extension that just
looks like sumerian text dude yeah it
does
what's gonna happen when your brain gets
used to it and then it has to
be just kidding news yeah
i have to remember it i already hear my
mom going like what does this say i
can't read it
no it's like she gotta do the old lady
[ __ ] like this with the glasses
yeah i can already hear her i do that
[ __ ] now yeah i
actually used it last night to study for
the hell today did it help out
i don't know we'll find out but so far
so good
but it was kind of cool because it looks
crazy it looks like you're reading some
like alien
text it's like blade runner i can't
remember [ __ ] anymore dude
you know when we were younger we used to
be able to like remember lyrics to songs
like nothing yeah i don't know [ __ ] now
dude
i'm not complicated you can't understand
the lyrics now that's true that's what
it is
it doesn't make sense oh it's crazy
your printer is running out of ink and
when you look at a lot of them looks
like a bunch of ants crawling on the
screen
but then you can clearly read it though
like read that yeah sans verde
sans for getting cut is decidedly odd
looking it slides backwards and there
are gaps in all the letters how does
this
right retention yeah like isn't it like
it looks crazy but
you can't actually just clear it are you
guys good at reading upside down
nope nope i could barely read it that
makes me vomit dude i actually traded
myself a little bit
really i purposely for like a few years
right upside down really wide
just because would you do a handstand
read backwards like flavored pistachios
because every time
every time they they like turn the paper
around
and then like they're telling you like
the corrections i'm like how do you read
that or they can write upside down
like dang teachers are superheroes i
don't know
but hey you got amazed by everything as
a kid that's pretty cool
[ __ ] yeah i'm very simple i want that
type of innocence dude
it's like mariel she's like amazed by
everything we were when we were
in um [ __ ] kauai you know that fern
when you touch it it just closes i love
that [ __ ] i have that same plant at my
house
and then we're on this tour i love that
she's full of adults and then [ __ ]
mariel
she's just the lady she goes so this
plant when you touch it it folds up and
it shows its thorns and he touches and
it goes in mario as an adult she goes
[Laughter]
whoa i'm like that girl is [ __ ] cute
you [ __ ] embarrassing [ __ ]
you were embarrassed no i don't get
embarrassed by that [ __ ] come on now
look at me
come on leprechaun green right no but
that's just why you're owning the
leprechaun green
yeah i like to uh own my embarrassment
but it was it's pretty funny i didn't
realize because i spent two weeks with
her
there's it's it's not common that i see
her face for 14 days straight
you know so like just observing her that
close is like dude this girl is pretty
[ __ ] funny man
she's like cracking me up wow
she's just a [ __ ] ass girl dude i was
cracking up dude
yeah i love that [ __ ] too what [ __ ]
that's her
[Laughter]
not the cute stuff i knew i had to
clarify
is he talking about the girl behavior
i'm like i don't know i gotta it's true
i gotta figure it out and sure enough
i wasn't thinking what he was thinking i
know how that feels like
what does so you share the same reaction
the first so where are you like mario
then
like we do have to clarify it's like
wait what is he saying
and he's still saying the funniest
option of the two too yeah
oh god that's awesome wait what's
awesome going outside
it's like all right i already know what
it does
and it still surprises me till this day
what does it do
it closes but like why the movement i
like the movement because it's like
so slow slide trap yeah like the way
plants those type of plants move
it's like i like that it's it has this
like weird
i call that plant the shy korean girl um
yeah that's what it reminds me of the
shy korean girl plant it's like the
[ __ ]
uh that move from smooth criminal where
you're just like leaning and [ __ ]
yeah yeah so did you guys ever have
trouble like when you were studying and
cramming and like trying
all the [ __ ] time i can't remember
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
my test would always go like this
specifically in college 50
of the time i i know half of the answers
right and the other half was just a
[ __ ] guessing game dude
oh cause then that other half this font
would have helped you because they're
saying that they would retent
uh 50 more retention not me
i used to [ __ ] read the first
sentence like 10 times because
in the middle of the sentence i start
thinking about other [ __ ] oh yeah
oh yep like have you ever done that
while you're reading a textbook
and you're just like [ __ ] the [ __ ]
photo synthesis
is that this kind of looks like weed let
me just see if i can just look at the
picture
and see if i can memorize the picture
dude [ __ ] i got that
for me i'll keep reading but i'm
thinking that and then i'm still reading
i'm still reading you have to go back
mind is somewhere else and i'm like oh
wait what the [ __ ] did i just read
yeah i'm even like that with my own
scripts that i write dude i'm like
reading it i'm like this is [ __ ]
boring dude
i just move on something else dude it's
like my own [ __ ] it's [ __ ] annoying i
card
80d like a [ __ ] man it's super
hard i found out i studied the best when
um i started the best when uh
well how does his voice get clear when
you quit how'd that happen dude
that's just what happens when you get
married bart's like i really gotta fart
got you babe oh sometimes i think
that when i'm like about to fall asleep
and i really have to go pee and i'm like
and then casey's already peeing i'm like
oh i wish you could take my pee with you
because i don't want to go
that's the laziest thing i've ever met
like i'm about to fall asleep you know
how that feels
i never know what it's like to fall
asleep dude if i need to pee i can't
pack
up like i can't go to sleep i could
ignore it
what were you gonna say i helped me when
i recorded the lecture so i have to like
hear it and read it at the same time
oh you're maybe a audio learner that's
when i but then if i just listen
i don't remember that much too you know
what helped me gotta do both
i would sit next to the smartest person
and i was just like
ty what about when you started going to
college where everyone has a different
test
um no then i had to say that it was i
was just [ __ ] up they really
tripped it up like i had some college
classes where there's like the tests
were like a b
c d right so like they they pass it out
so everyone around me is already
different
now they go okay every other person
switch with the person to your right so
now you're shuffling the papers too
and they're just like no matter how you
prepped it
there's there's no way you could cheat
except if you leave a text but in the
bathroom so it asks go use the bathroom
a couple times
and i'll go just double check in the
bathroom dude i'm so bad at studying
that even when i was learning how to
make coffee
uh in sacramento for you know sip there
is no
right or wrong answer but habitually
what i did i kept on looking at anna's
paper i went
[Music]
and i caught myself what the [ __ ] am i
doing dude
that was my old study habit yeah so like
anna's just i'm like
you know that's so bad dude it's like
still trying to copy and try to copy
dude
i like wrote her name on my paper oh my
god
like [ __ ] you're not you're like i'm
not i'm not gonna like try to get
anything not even a test and [ __ ] it's
not even a [ __ ] let me see your
answers
because how do you feel i was like well
how do you feel oh my god
all right for our next story amazon
tried building an
ai tool to help them recruit people
but they ended up discovering that it
showed a bias against
women see right there you know what that
just proves men are superior because a.i
cannot do that name something that can
bleed for a whole week and not die
what can believe for a whole week and
not die a tree bleed
trees bleach yeah maple syrup that's
blood that's blood that's tree
that's tree blood nah dude
proven wrong i'm talking about that
mammal blood [ __ ]
face well that's pretty amazing but
something uh something else give me
something else
okay how about this i could also bleed
for a week and not die
you sure about that a hundred percent no
way dude prick me right now
i remember someone calling me from the
hospital the er to be exact and they
were bleeding profusely and they're like
i think i'm gonna die and it was only
like a couple hours yeah you know what
we can't share that story
i didn't even care what the story was i
just said you went to the er and you
bled a lot
well that's like well then fine i'm
alive aren't i how often do i go to the
er
i go to the er so much i'm the employee
of the month there do you understand
that's how often i'm there yeah yeah
women roar i'll be in the [ __ ] fight
chip somebody's like i heard something
i'm like what did you heard dude
what did you hurt why was the ai
only choosing men so the reason why this
ai was biased against women is because
it had combed through predominantly
male resumes over that 10 year period
of data that they gave this ai so they
pre-biased it
yeah exactly so they're the ones i mean
always like the ai is not gonna like
naturally be biased it's just always how
it's
programmed until there's a woman on pms
next to the ai and he's in like oh
[ __ ] this one's kind of mean you know
what [ __ ]
you know what [ __ ] uh i read on the
twitters that really got me though that
made me like feel for women like a
hundred percent though
this lady was describing her experience
just to you know like a lot of people
complain on twitter
but this one was like oh [ __ ] i feel for
women because she was talking about like
just the difference between what a woman
has to go through and what a guy has to
go through from something very simple
like posting something up on craigslist
right so she posted something up on
craigslist and she was trying to sell
her dryer washer i read that [ __ ] right
i read that [ __ ] and that [ __ ] made me
feel for women so much you still haven't
said anything oh so so you know it's
such a different experience so if i put
something up on craigslist and i have a
dude come to my house
yeah i'm scared right like a little bit
i'm a little weary yeah yeah yeah yeah
but
i still wouldn't be so scared to the
point where it's like well i have a gun
i'll just [ __ ] blast this dude
right but if for her she was like it's a
different feeling for a woman if a guy
comes over and this guy came over
and then he didn't really want to buy
the washer and dryer but he literally
just harassed her just be like what's up
what's your name
hell in that moment she literally felt
she could be raped or something like
that you know what i mean that's not
something that goes through my mind when
that happens i just think that this dude
just might rob me
and i'll [ __ ] murder this dude if
that happens so that just that
scenario alone i was like oh [ __ ] dude
sometimes it's scary being a girl in
this world dude [ __ ] yeah what's
something we were trying to like come
like get you guys to understand
a lot i understand i just like to joke
around no i remember like
we were trying to help you guys and
because you would be like
so what if someone sees me naked like i
don't care that's what you that's
it okay bart i said that particularly
they were just like i don't care like
let them see that's their fault and i'm
like
but there's that added fear like you
don't know if like what's gonna happen
like what if they're gonna come into
your home and like rape you and like pin
you down and obviously you don't have
that fear because you're strong and you
can always
fight something you could get strong too
yeah but it's just like how
it doesn't matter how strong she gets
she's never going to get you or david
off of her
i got my ass kicked by a girl that's
smaller than tiff but you still
there's a video of it with my
but what you said too was like i felt
bad even going
hard on her though no because she did
her makeup i don't want to smear it
that's cultural conditioning yeah that's
where i got [ __ ] up where i was like i
should have smeared her makeup because
she beat the [ __ ] out of me
she really did though but you know like
i i when i read that i was like
it's true because i didn't really think
about it in the sense that in her case
because i always think about it for
mario right so that's why i had this
rule where i'm like
hey whenever you get home you text me if
you don't text me i feel like something
bad happened to you
that's so nice and i can't go to sleep
so for her like i need to know that
she's
for you because then you can't go to
sleep 100 it is 100
i can't go to sleep oh mary you better
be safe yeah
i feel like i like i've been compton
there's all these dudes with guns out
but i think i'm safe oh good good that's
what it is i'm in compton texted me
i'm in danger i'm like but you texted me
so i don't know how to feel
you're safe now i recently heard from
one of my friends how she was
done dirty like that from a cable guy
like you know no one was home and she
was home alone i don't like that the
cable guy came
and then like um he would ask her like
oh can you plug that in or whatever and
help me do this or whatever and then she
walked up
and like she heard a and she's like what
the [ __ ] and she realized that
he was uh he was doing upskirt photos oh
yeah so when she she called
or like texted her boyfriend called the
police
when she had the chance to and then he
was like making some crazy advances and
boom
the cops came immediately he uh admitted
that he was like yeah i was doing this
and they found all these other photos
of women's skirts upskirts and all that
go to
jail yeah and like she you know she's
like
she she ended up suing the company
pretty [ __ ] hard yeah and she won
but um she was like that experience was
really scary it could have been worse
yeah man could have been really worse
because it nothing went down past that
but it's like imagine all the women that
because there's a lot of
there was a lot of photos in that phone
yeah i'm just like damn dude
so that's why i'm like oh man i wish
women were more violent
because they need to catch these people
these criminals
carla esparza doesn't have that problem
well carla carla esparza's neck is the
same size of waist
so you know all right for our next story
this cheerleader in michigan
she was pretty much bribing everyone in
her school with pop brownies
in order for them to like vote for her
whatever for this
like homecoming thing damn she's smart
she's desperate i'd vote for her like a
[ __ ]
hell yeah but can i vote for you twice
yeah
so yeah they're saying that authorities
recovered only three out of the 12
brownies that she gave out because she
was giving it out to the football team's
homecoming week goodie bags
yeah yeah that she was just trying to
get them to like
support her for the homecoming dance
that's an investment i didn't know they
did that in college
no this is high school high school yeah
that's crazy that it's so serious for
her that she's
she's going to go out of her way to make
some hot brownies to
win homecoming i mean like they would on
a regular though they would bake [ __ ]
and then like give
[ __ ] to people and then like when they
campaign right
like that's normal but like but she's
like
she's an extra credit kind of person
like you guys smoke weed we all party
let me just put some [ __ ] thc
in that [ __ ] it's weird that you say you
like brownies because i know you don't
like chocolate
i don't but brownie says it's i don't
know there's just enough mixture of it
that it's pretty good and i like the way
it feels because it's crunchy on top and
then moisture if it's done right brownie
oh that's a good brownie right there i
know the good good because there's fudge
brownies style too
like fudge brownies like just soft all
around and it's kind of dense
something about a brownie in milk man so
good dude
you know when i was a freshman i was
trying to run for a high school office
like one of the lower ones it was like
i don't know chair of like treasure or
some [ __ ] some [ __ ]
after that something like that and then
uh i was like man all you guys are whack
with your typical campaigning with
[ __ ] balloons and
baked goods so i found an old uh tv box
and i i opened it up so it's one big
cardboard box
then i got spray paint and it was baby
blue and white and i wrote vote for me
with spray paint and i put it up in the
middle of the school quad
and then immediately after i put it up
the teacher pulled it down for graffiti
so now no one even knew i was running i
was like [ __ ]
i spent like eight hours [ __ ] making
this art piece and immediately my
campaign is gone
do they have like guidelines or
something i don't know i just
i just want to do things my way so i
folded it up right and i pulled it down
and then on uh
bloomfield and [ __ ] about the other
cross street we have a marquee for the
high school
i was like [ __ ] these [ __ ] they
don't let me campaign in the middle of
the quad i'm gonna do it
in the front of the school so you know
what the marquee will be like cerritos
high school
and they'll be like homecoming dance
november whatever i got
a tape and i taped it on the marquee
then the guidance counselor came out
and saw me taping and she gave me
detention wait it just said vote for me
yeah it says vote for me and i wrote
bart at the bottom oh yeah cause i was
like what if it's a vote for me and i'm
like but who do i vote
it's because i just learned how to
attack m in a certain way
so i wanted to put that that that kind
of ended that was the type of like art
that they just immediately thought it
was
hey you know that so in that whole day
for the eight hours that you were making
that [ __ ] how much
how much fun have you been doing your
homework none exactly
he probably would skip school to do that
because those are the only school things
that i did
like in eighth grade i think the only
homework i did was in social studies you
had to make something from the medieval
period so i bought
balsa wood and a glue gun i made like a
giant catapult
oh this is gonna be a fun homework i
don't wanna do that paper [ __ ]
they're like too bad
[ __ ] bart that wasn't the excitement
it was just a [ __ ] take-home quiz i
just look what i did
[Laughter]
i don't even remember doing the whole
failing this class [ __ ]
i was down to do homework i just wanted
it to be fun did you do homework cause
the way i did homework was i
bubbled in whatever like b a whatever
and multiple choice
i just [ __ ] turned it in no i never
did i never looked at it read it nothing
i did every project because i wanted to
do projects because they're fun but i
never did anything i would hate you as a
student dude
like this is the homework for today
you're just like nah
go a little bigger catapult this is the
[Music]
homework
[Music]
you